hello reject nation
I'm Greg Alba
I'm Andrew we're gonna talk about
daredevil season 3 sound good mr.
D'Onofrio we're late to the game while
talking about it a little bit
apparently everyone else in the world
has 13 disposable hours at their hands
you finished it like a while ago a week
or two yeah I finished it only like
three days ago and I've seen a lot of
things since then so a lot of this is
gonna be jogging the memory so this is
more fresh in your mind a little more
except I feel like we should probably
should have made notes before filming
because no we're too smart or too smart
for that we'd rather just talk forever
then I'll spend hours editing it down
before we hop into this I wanted to say
thank you to everyone who's been
following us on the Stardust app yo over
there it's 30 second reactions for any
film TV show or trailer there's a lot of
micro sketches that we do on there as
well
I even covered most of Iron Fist over on
that app it's free to use free to
download I would say do it right now
because I asked you to so kindly why
don't we just give basic thoughts and
then we'll dive into some spoilers all
the way I like to do spoiler reviews
it's not like let's break down this
whole season because we'd be here for 26
hours I'm just gonna talk about whatever
really stands out and comes to my mind
and in this moment or whatever comes to
your mind but what are your general
thoughts on season 3 I mean overall I I
found myself entertained I really
enjoyed it I thought for the most part
was well paced I mean there was a couple
times it was predictable where I was
able to call things out for sure but I
mean this point in time there's it's
hard to you know get to the point where
I'm not shocked and surprised if you
can't do that it's amazing but there
were some moments were for sure I was
like oh I didn't see that coming I agree
there were some predictable moments but
overall the action was pretty good
Vincent D'Onofrio is just so incredible
and I really like the portrayal of
bullseye in this season for me it's
first yeah so yeah yeah that was some
good stuff I just I will say one thing
negative that probably get some hate for
I don't like Karen page oh they're gonna
hate for that I don't know anyone who
likes Karen page gets on my nerves
what situation I mean I'm on the verge
of tears it every moment I'm talking
I like this season I do I want to make
that clear because I feel like
especially when you're talking about
comic book related material if you if
you have a criticism oftentimes you
start to over explain so that way you're
like I know people are gonna give me
some backlash for criticizing this so
I'm gonna over explain it and suddenly
the video turns into this comment box
thread of you just hate this thing don't
you I'm like no I just got caught up in
over at explaining so I don't want to
harp on my criticisms too harshly I
really enjoyed this season what's good
about it is good what's great about it
is like a lot of the same things that
you probably you're all around you know
a lot of people really prefer this
season over season two it's definitely
better than defenders by like oh yeah I
personally found this to be my least
favorite daredevil season i if I'm being
totally transparent
I appreciated more than I actually
really did like from the heart in a
weird way of why I feel like the effect
is diminished there was something about
season 1 and season 2 that felt like
something special something of an event
and then halfway through this show it
was a little bit after when daredevil
meets bullseye for the first time
there's a little bit after that moment
when I realized here it was just another
show now everything that was predictable
was the overall arc of the season Matt
starts off as this guy who's like I
don't want any friends you know he's
back to that and you're like okay so by
the end of this season he's probably
gonna be friends with Karen and foggy
like a ride towards the yet he's
probably gonna get Nelson and Murdock
backing again going fist is gonna go
back to jail and like all those arcs
make sense it's like of course that's
where we go I think the only one that
was kind of annoying to me that I
predicted oh he's not gonna be bullseye
officially in this season they're gonna
end it in a way where it's a cliffhanger
and then they're gonna go into season 4
where bullseye as probably the main
villain when it ended on that specific
scene was like wow and I predicted that
like on the second episode it's like the
way how it ended was very much
predictable from the first couple
episodes so there was a lot of lack of
excitement for me during it don't get me
wrong there's a lot of really
intensity in it there's still some
amazing performances I just felt that
there was something about its style that
I thought wasn't as visually striking
and I think that's because a lot of it
is during the day season one and two is
more I'm really night and then season
three you know you see Wilson fists
tearing out the the penthouse in the
daytime a lot of time Daredevils walk in
the night so a lot of that striking
visual imagery I didn't really find as
much as a like --which at which I think
is in effect to its tone and effect to
how everything else sort of plays out
and also a little too much guests or
something important in the show where
I'm like where did the writers think we
need more Karen page you know what it
hit me when that really got on my nerves
it was when there's that cliffhanger
moment of one of the episodes of where
Poindexter's being sent to go kill Karen
page it's like always gonna go to the
church we're gonna get that church scene
and then half of the next episode is
dedicated to her backstory yeah like why
would you slow down the momentum of this
intensity by episode I didn't hear and I
didn't feel was necessary to the story I
mean I get where they were trying to go
with that you know give her a
sympathetic backstory and pass you know
you know why she's so up now and yeah I
know why she does what she does but just
like and I agree with you there was
definitely predictable stuff where I
first year saw that coming for me the
way it was executed in the way I saw it
you know play out on on the screen it
didn't bother me as much even though I
saw them coming I'm not saying that I
hope for predictable stuff not at all I
prefer like to see moments where wow I
didn't see that coming that's done in a
very interesting you know way and maybe
it's because at this point I'm so
invested in the characters at least with
Charlie Cox and especially with I really
love what they did this season with
Wilson Fisk with kingpin we all know how
he's physical faretta I just love how
they get into the house marty is like
how we methodically just plans things
out that makes him more of a scary
villain to me when like he's not it's
not just about how physical he's like
he's like very intelligent the way like
he manipulates characters in the way he
puts fear into characters it's just done
and aware like this is one of my
favorite MCU villains
far2 me in the first season at daredevil
I love Wilson Fisk mm-hmm I still
thought Charlie Cox his performances
Matt Murdock was still my favorite one
though
I like hands down he was one of the
season one and then in this season I
found myself going I want to get back to
kingpin it was to the point where I was
kind of hoping the season would end
where he would win because he was easily
the best part of the season yeah
I mean Charlie Cox in my opinion
consistently great as always
Charlie Costas has my heart for life
agent Poindexter the guy plays him it's
great job I have some questions about
some stuff with Poindexter that I want
to bring up later but overall great
performance there was something about
the way they they dealt with who he's
deteriorating into and his skill set
that towards the last few episodes of
the season that whenever main characters
were out side of a place where they were
safe or if they were within vicinity of
Poindexter I was worried for them
because I'm like just don't get near him
he'll kill you yeah I like the idea of
how he didn't just have like knives on
him at any moment of Jackie Chan his way
around just grab something and if it's
sharp enough he gets thrown at you and
he could kill you with it you know that
was a cool thing and it did get
obviously and not we're not gonna go
into the 2003 daredevil movie but they
did get very cartoonish and you know all
the stuff that he could do because he
was like flicking peanuts into old women
you know and then the Colin Farrell grew
flavor they were pretty close together
there were a lot of moments to her I
thought it did feel a little ground in
terms of like I can actually by him
doing that but there were definitely
moments where I Greek got it was getting
close but I still felt it was for the
most part I thought it was pretty
grounded and I like this this take on
and also too I like the slow build-up
just like again getting into the psyche
of the character and just like and again
his backstory I was I thought was well
done like Anne Hale Wilson you know with
how he was studying him and all that and
we were getting into all that so that
was great I thought that was really like
it I'm getting the profile and really
putting himself in the mindset of this
person so he can manipulate him and know
what role he has won is really and one
other thing I want to mention
watching Wilson Fisk manipulate
Poindexter I kept on harping back to
Revenge of the Sith and thinking why
couldn't George Lucas write it this way
with Emperor Palpatine manipulation is
so much more interesting in the cooler
that was one of the more interesting
dynamics in this show is those two I
love the way that methodically just
built up that relationship and their
chemistry together like those two
together very importantly honest I just
really enjoyed their scenes and kept on
wanting more and obviously with what
happened with the the girl that point
Dexter you know was talking to and when
ends up happening her like I was kind of
getting scared towards the end that they
weren't gonna go then and you know when
Matt brought it up saying okay good they
stuck with that because obviously he's
you know you had to see him kind of turn
on Wilson at some points it was very
obvious that was obvious you see it like
I agree with that I mean I want to get
too hung up on criticisms because I
don't want people to think like that's
my only takeaway I don't mind if
something's predictable as long as I am
okay with the execution yeah but I did
have some issues with certain executions
because the first couple episodes have
this sort of immediacy like oh we're
just hop right into this aren't we where
I was like oh this is pretty cool and
then there were other points in the show
where I thought it was a little bit
meandering where I'm like we don't
really need it like gosh we're gonna
have another karen and matt talking
about Matt being mad and care and being
Karen thing and Oh Matt why are you
being just in like a lot of repetitive
miss in this series before yeah it was
so repetitive and and sometimes I
thought it's like symbolism with
implementing Catholicism is a lot of
symbolic ways I kind of found
pretentious and not poetic if that makes
sense
there were times where I'm like you
clearly want to be poetic but then there
are times where like dude these shots of
you like looking at the church after
these speeches just kind of seem cheesy
to me now they don't seem as badass as
you probably want them to hit although
within there there's like this series is
kind of just a mixture of things I love
and things I didn't like because within
there I love the relationship dynamics
between Matt and his mom those were
one of my favorite elements in this
series the fact that she was a nun what
I love about movies and shows priests
and nuns whenever their main characters
they're always like the coolest priests
and nuns you never like they don't ever
act like real nuns and priests and her
personality her dynamics and her history
I could feel that in that actresses
performance this guilt and trying to
right the wrongs that she feels really
bad about with him and trying to take
care of a guy who really doesn't want to
be taken care of but probably in the
back of his mind does those are some
really awesome dynamics that were going
on and and I like in the first three
episodes that kind of has his Dark
Knight Rises vibe did you pick up on
that yeah no I did like I mean because
obviously he's really fast you
definitely add that vibe too for sure
and fun fact to the actress who plays
his mom she was in willow and was
married to Val Kilmer one thing why I do
want to mention though how awesome was
that that fight scene in the jail where
he was that was amazing
like I thought that was incredible I
think like episodes four through eight
or something like that or solid there's
the middle portion of this episode of
like the episode after the when all that
church stuff ended was when I started
like okay now I feel like we're
deteriorating again because the first
three episodes were fine and then that
middle portion was great when you get to
that uh that prison scene I I had heard
that there's a one-shot scene in here I
had no idea was gonna be that long what
I loved about that one shot sequence is
it's very different than the first and
second season one the first season is
this long hallway five words like badass
choreography the second one is one
that's tracking him as he's going
through a building and going down the
stairs it was it was a real badass fight
with a lot of intense choreography and
then in this one he's not suited up and
he's wearing a suit but he's not he's
not Neville suited up right you can see
it's Charlie Cox it feels like a prison
riot but there's also scene work in
there where he's talking with the
albanian guy and you're keeping the plot
moving forward there's a real level of
intensity and it feels more realistic
than the other ones so while the the
choreography of in terms of like martial
arts movements is nowhere near on par as
season one and two this one was way more
intense than those because of what
at stake that reveal that Fiske is
watching him he'll and if this knows
there was a lot of emotional intensity
that was not there as strong or as
prevalent in season one tattoos one shot
sequence and I'd agree with that and
also to one thing I really appreciate in
these fights is you really feel the
blows when they're being hailed I love
the fight choreography they have on all
three seasons a daredevil it's just very
well done so I feel like other than the
fight scene the first one between
Poindexter and daredevil at the bulletin
most of the fights were a lot more
grounded actually yeah it's primarily
Matt just doing boxing moves he's not
really kicking a lot makes sense with
his body injuries I don't know if that
was the choice of because of that but if
you look at most of the fights in this
season he's primarily just punching even
that fight at the bullet like that was
intense
the trailers gave it away so much who
when they get to the bullets in it and
he's killing everyone you're like what
holy crap he's murdering left and right
and that fight was good that was a good
fight because Matt's doing the boxing
he's winning and then point Dexter's are
skating hand on him in and Daredevil's
figure it out they're like [ __ ] he
supply that's around him he's gonna use
it you know and the framing set up like
I also have to admit something - I read
the born-again graphic novel and I heard
that this season is primarily inspired
from that it's not a direct adaptation
writer it's very much inspired by some
visual references yeah I had those comic
book geek out moments several times
where I was watching it going oh my god
that's one from the porn again comment
like I had that quite a bit actually
that was really nice for me would point
Dexter right the guy was so psychotic in
such an insecure way and also I really
like agent Indian Bo go back to that
later the guy was so psychotic and not
in like he's a genius psychotic he's
very highly insecure that I had to
question it and go how the hell did this
guy who's this insecure get all the way
to being an FBI agent that threw me off
and also the level of like how crazy he
was would certain moments of just like
grabbing anything and he'd get through
it there were times where it seemed a
little ridiculous
did say that it created this level of
fear in the atmosphere whenever people
were outside or if he was a rat
simultaneously though there were moments
where I'm like that's just that's just
ridiculous
the one where he killed the coach with
the baseball I'm a baseball instructor
so I can tell you that's horseshit
yeah and again it it's comic-book
character and see you but I get it but
you're the rules you've established with
Poindexter's he's a human being and
that's it they haven't established
anything about him having any superhuman
thing in here when he kills that one I
think it's a homeless guy or something
or it breaks it beer ball he's pissed
does the church thing went wrong and
he's just like doesn't even look at his
throws it gets him the jugular like
actor wasn't so good I would have more
issues with that because I'm like I get
what this dude's performance is it's
really good make a good point but I
think that's kind of why I was a little
more forgiving for those cartoonish
moments because there was more a blend
of like I said grounded moments where
they did have it where I'm like actually
I do buy that when he is throwing that
but like I said the baseball one in a
couple of their moments you're like
how's he able to do I will say that
obviously with that it creates you know
a sort of a threat level where like you
know you really have a fear for him
because he could obviously just you know
yeah but but especially the last like
two episodes yeah when Matt and Nadeem
or like on the run every time they're
outside of a building or even in the
final fight when Vanessa's in the room
I'm like to get Poindexter you know that
threat level is so good special agent
Nadine special agent deem it was a
wonderful addition I'm a brown guy
obviously I want to say that for a
reason as a preface to what I'm about to
say now this is just a side note when
Nadine first showed up it dawned on me
it when we learned who his character is
how I've been programmed by television
to assume that if someone is speaking
Hindi they're probably a bad guy first
they're I'm like oh [ __ ] he's mad at his
wife about the bills he's gonna hit or
isn't he's gonna do something evil there
you know and then he goes yeah yeah oh
wait he's a good guy who's the show try
to do that or his television programming
telling me we're probably supposed to be
a bad guy
speaking Hindi and stuff but I really
like his performance very sympathetic
see that's a predictable thing that I
could forgive like it was so obvious to
me that his female boss was working for
Fisk
like that was very obvious to me and it
was also very obvious that he's gonna
like it was so apparent like he's
probably gonna die that helped and that
wasn't like I predicted it 10 minutes
before it happened as predictable in the
sense of few episodes before it was like
becoming very apparent I guess I keep
heart around this point cuz I'm fine
with predictability as long as the show
can give me a moment where I'm like wait
a minute is whatever it is it not gonna
happen the show never gave me that
that's like when you watch The Dark
Knight though like I remember the first
time you watch The Dark Knight you get
to a point you're like it's bad they
gonna lose in this movie you know when
the predictability is he's not gonna
lean oh yeah yeah does it feel like he's
gonna yeah the thing is I never had any
time I predicted something I never felt
that I was off that's what I mean by
lack of effect ins and that's fair I
guess that's why I've been harping on
that point you're the only one I've
talked with about daredevil season 3 yes
oh I haven't had my thoughts very clear
on this so far what's special agent and
deem of the part of that I appreciate
with him the most yes was very
sympathetic and I just felt like to me
like and there were many moments where
he felt like the audience like if we
were in this situation like what would
we do like I just I really appreciated
those moments or like you know when
Wilson Fisk is Bonnie and he's like
literally yeah trapped and there's
nothing he can do his leg I can't beat
Wilson Fisk we she did those moments I
just I just really like what got
invested in that particular character
and like what he was going through what
he had to gain from his wife what he had
to deal with I mean obviously we saw the
the Boston coming but clearly obviously
he didn't and then when that whole thing
his whole world just got flipped upside
down I like the you know the the flip
that they had to do on that character
and like with what was going on it's
just his motivation is really well built
I was so impressed with how they built
his motivation for why he's trying to
get this job done with Fisk why he's you
know like he's really committed to this
even though it's a dangerous position
even when he has that moment where he's
revealing to Matt and the DA when he's
saying why he didn't just go to like I'm
so happy the show raised this question
and then you get the answer and I'm
like.he you know what
you just can't blame the guy and the
fact that he was willing to pay for
those consequences and that had a good
line of your son's gonna remember you as
a man who stood up to Wilson Fisk that's
what's important even if you go to jail
and Adeem was I was a highlight of the
season for me Matt he's the moral
compass of the season yeah yeah and like
the fact that he had to Teeter on the on
the bad side was was really compelling
like you can't blame the time or the
position would you do situation how
could you you either die in your face or
your family dies and the only way to
figure out how to win is you got to play
along for a while yeah like so his whole
his whole choices made sense to me and I
mean they did get into that a little too
with his boss cuz she said because he's
like why are you doing this is like I
had two children one of them made it
look like it was a hidden run just shows
you the power of Wilson Fisk what he
does why he's pimping yeah I think I
like how they called him kingpin in this
specific season he's earned it he earned
it because in the first season you're
like yeah he's the bad guy
I get it the cool thing about the season
one it has this effect where when you
learn about why Wilson Fisk does what he
does you get where he's coming from and
you can see he's just got a more twisted
version of wanting to help the city this
season though you're like oh he's just
evil you know that's why I loved what
they do like he goes from a villain I
understand - this guy is evil yeah it
was cool to get to a point of I'm
beginning to hate him now for the right
reason yeah yeah yeah good hate yeah not
like not like I can't stand this
character that Foreman sucks but like
because he's so evil is so interesting
whenever he's not on the screen I'm
always saying more kingpin so no for
sure because it's it's a pretty
ludicrous plot that think had heard a
guy from prison be able to manipulate
and work the FBI but as the season
unfolds it does such a good job at
getting you to like II I believe it by
the time you get to the last couple
episodes of the show one of the good
things about it that I really love
everywhere in Hell's Kitchen feels like
a threat level at this point you can't
trust anyone everywhere they go someone
might just be in a disguise who's ready
to shoot someone it does a really good
job at building that up and Matt there's
something about
Matt Murdock in this season I totally
got what they were going for and like
I'm a big fan of born-again comic I
totally got what they were going for and
it made sense why he would start out in
the position that he was in at the
beginning of the season from what
happened in defenders yeah and factoring
in the other two seasons it was just the
fact that he ended exactly where it was
predictable I thought you could have
gotten there earlier you didn't have to
make it the finale arc of his character
his coolest moments were still when you
know when he first confronts the demon
his hyung and he he's the one who gets
through Nadeem about like you don't
understand what's going on here now I
get in the cool daredevil fashion that
he doesn't know she could have gone in
there a little earlier with NAT Murdock
and I like how it ends on him just
showing his face to kingpin and stuff
and that that final fight was one of the
weirdest fights and coolest fights I've
seen in a while
definitely a weird fight in terms of how
it was choreography yeah all three are
fighting each other for a very different
purpose
fighting Kings trying to kill them but
it was that's trying to take them down
Matt's trying to make sure they don't
kill anyone trying to make sure that
whole sequence I was so concerned
vanessa was going to see how D'Onofrio
or kingpin would have reacted to that
like that was a really intense fight
like it ends with Wilson Fisk you'll
find a way to manipulate his way out
that's what Wilson Fisk does I mean what
else happens in this season foggy foggy
foggy foggy really annoy me in season
two but I like him here I like that we
got to see his family that motivation
there I think him and what's this
girlfriend's worst Marci yeah I actually
liked him as a couple whenever he was on
Matt's case about Matt it wasn't about
stop be a good man I like how they at
least work on changing that it was all
about being concerned for Matt and
wanting to stay connected to him not
trying to change him from being rebel
think he knows at this point negative
gene yeah it's not going to change and I
also like that they weren't trying to
have Karen Matt you know freakin hook up
again or so I was happy about that so
that was for sure for me it's a mixed
bag of a lot of things I love it
something's and there's nothing I really
hated other than some Karen page stuff
like I don't think Deborah
about actress I don't want to give that
a depression I think the writing of hers
is oh one note of like she's always very
suppressed and victim you know it's very
annoying and foggy I thought was an
improvement
I liked you know cleaned up sharp
looking foggy who's at the top of his
game you know he's he had some really
good dynamite scenes in here him and
Matt had some really sweet moments too
and like aspect of the way very
predictable obviously but the way it
adds with I mean that's good though
yeah but the way it ends and like again
the execution of it like I appreciated
that and to see that that relationship
and that law firm get back the way it
was supposed to be like you know it
makes me like look forward to the future
for sure this whole videos been me
trying to figure out why I'm harping on
the predictability doctor the reason
I've been harping on it is because I
thought there were no surprises no
that's why I feel like it was just
another [ __ ] also - you made a good
point like I don't mind predictability
when if you can make me think oh wait
maybe what I thought I predicted might
not actually a oh wait did have but it's
like it takes your mind off of that but
it's like nope it's just a gap of what I
thought like even right down to when the
priest died the second that was stuff
the second Matt confronts him it was
like oh he's gonna do that right when
Matt was yelling at him I'm like bye-bye
yeah what happened at the end what they
were doing surgery on him yes so they're
fixing his back and then is that it I'm
gonna go to prison matter and now he's
got his identity of bullseye I kind of
separate the words cliche and lazy to
sometimes I don't think they coexist
sometimes cliche is separate from lazy
that cliffhanger I actually thought was
really lazily done the surgeons are
having this conversation there what did
you have had this conversation in pre-op
stage yeah surgery like and then he and
then they have this like cheesy ass shot
or he wakes up in the middle of surgery
just totally did not fit with the
entirety of the other season did it I
think it's enjoyable season there's
plenty I love about it there I just I
don't know I feel like overall the grand
scheme of things it's just another dare
all season to me it's not something
special - I don't know it's not as
special as the others I'm not gonna get
into a ranking and do I like this better
than season one or two I would just say
I love all three seasons they're all
unique and special to me in certain
different ways in terms of quality I
thought it was right up there I was
entertained by the time we got to the
13th episode yeah there was maybe that
one Karen page backstory episode was
like I didn't think that was necessary
but overall I wanted more because
usually by the time we get to like
episode 9 or 10 I'm probably just by
myself in this I'm like I kind of wanted
to just end already but I didn't find
myself saying that in this I'm like I
kind of want more you know I kind of
want more so it's we're usually like
exactly on the same page this is the
first time for any of these Netflix
wanna do comparison in terms of VCs and
what we just had this last few seasons
well we had just a good Jones season two
we had Luke Cage season two we had Iron
Fist season two and now we have
daredevil scene three five our daredevil
season three is my favorite of those
four we just named not even close and I
enjoyed those other three I just don't
think it was close I thought Daredevils
doing three was better than any of those
other three for me personally I think
this sees this season has so many things
that I overall love more than those
other seasons of the shows you name but
I think as a total of a season I would
prefer this mutation yesterday I prefer
that one
Oh Mateus folks you know I think it's
because I just hold daredevil to uh
unfairly unfairly I hold daredevil to a
higher standard than the other shows I
really loved our first season - but you
know pulling into the mantle in as big
of as a bar as I'm setting with
daredevil to me I just I really hold
that to a higher bar and I actually
think it's probably I don't know unfair
rating but it's fair I mean you're still
saying you enjoyed it you really alight
the season but there's a lot there's a
lot more things you could pick apart
criticism wise than you could for
seasons 1 & 2 for instance yeah yeah the
level is standard for the fervor
daredevil is very high snatcher aliy as
you get a going in time it's gonna be
easier to pick apart things you know
that can that might bother you just
because again the standard
so high so that's totally understandable
appreciate you understanding I
understand you Greg I understand you
great yeah I remember like a six point
five to seven somewhere between there
six point seven out of ten yeah I'd
probably go more in like the eight point
seven range okay yeah yeah I'd say
seasons one to more like nine point four
nine point five range and I'd put this
like
season ones like ten at ten seasons he
was like eight point five for me and
this one's like yes these are the ones
like perfect one is perfect to me like
you didn't have seen it twice and I'm
like that's a perfect yeah if you got
someone's head being plopped off by an
Escalade or how can you get more than
that
what were your favorite moments of
daredevil season three comment below
what do you want to see yeah more Karen
but it art into them having Nelson
Murdock in page and like they're all
happy like I can't wait to get back to
season forward at all she's all
depressed and stressed again and he's
all dress and that's all like let's get
that back you guys can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
bell check us out and start us a
Pantages on the movie source channel
please show them some support subscribe
to them now has a lot of great content
see it gets